hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play SCP
containment breach okay let's get right
into it I'm gonna try to get some new
stuff as soon as possible or these guys
still there are you still there
you little yes Santa [ __ ] are you
still there you gone oh our cellar Hey
alright let's some solve this little
prominently quickly I'm gonna go around
them so that I can see the new stuff
that guy's still stuck in the doorway
well I hear you
oh you're stuck in that doorway now look
at him look at the duo the really really
really dumb duo of kappas alright is
there anything over here there's park
benches oh you haven't seen [ __ ] okay
you stay there right obviously they're
gonna be there wha
you didn't see anything here you didn't
see me cheating either come on go up up
up up
thank you okay now go up enough you do
not make me fall through the ground
there we go okay we're good finally now
let's see what we can reach over here if
there's anything new I am going to find
it
I'll pisser you gotta be kidding me
ah another one of these blockages I have
to go through these damn a navy/white
nine-tailed Fox douches they're just
everywhere I do not like them they're
gonna die
I
what tent elongate I don't even know
that's so stupid you shut up the stupid
announcer guy is just randomly shouting
out advice when nobody needs it I need
to get around him again god this is so
friggin annoying they get stuck in
doorways don't you dig that's a pretty
significant bug oh now they're not good
for them Oh
give them a big ole oh no that's gate B
I'm not supposed to get out of gate B
this is stupid this is die hey you back
off sonny jim let me go back over this
way who's Jack what I think that I get
no clip through that I'm such an idiot
ah god damn it all right you know what
I'm not even gonna no clip I don't need
to no clip I just need to sprint through
there gunfire well [ __ ] yes I do god
damn it
ah hey my life come on come on come on
come on there we go okay where are we
we're in the office we need to go haha
come on Jack hahaha ah these sons of
[ __ ]
this sons of [ __ ] it's not matches
the fans are [ __ ] skirt I'm not even
giving him a chance to come here ah gosh
lalala lalalala go around that tailgate
lalala lalala
okay so what was over here was over here
that I couldn't go this way
I forget was it another big old gate it
was son-of-a-bitch skate a [ __ ] where am
I supposed to go
fine fine I know what I'm I know I got a
not noclip through this area again oh I
hate going through here cuz scp-173 such
a dick he's a douche he's a mean one we
save he's at me mr. douche he really is
a dick he'll pop up around any corner
he'll murder you with his eyeballs he
wasn't there yay
I'm so happy who's a happy yay all right
we got a backtrack quite a bit I don't
even remember where where I where stuff
has already been I don't even know where
I've gone and nowhere gate B is now but
I can't go through gate baby turn I'm
trying to find new stuff it's always
supposed to go through there
I don't know let's try this whole deal
let's go up here turn off the power and
then try for something else okay primary
lighting letting back on okay Ramona
door control off that means that now the
computer SCP douche can't do nothin
he can't do nothing lighting it back on
was I supposed to turn primary lighting
off I have no idea I don't think so I
don't want it to be dark I just wanted
to like to go off okay alright that was
that nothing new there what's down there
how do I get down there huh oh I know
how I get down here okay this is the way
I got to go through this is not the same
as the other one so I got to go through
this one what's seen your dick is down
here where where are you where are you
you're done
I hear you over there but where are you
I know where you are now but I don't
like you anyway I how do I get out here
was that was that grab it
let's go I'm almost out of eyeballs ha
ha ha
you stay where's the exit where's the
ding damn exit
God there it is ok welcome boo - boo
Budda Budda Budda boo
we're okay ah [ __ ] have I gone through
here before I turned son of them rich oh
there's so many of these gates I didn't
know about it your son oh my god through
her I didn't think I went through here
before ah god damn it [ __ ] it out
okay
I hate you I hate you you a [ __ ] I hate
you so much I hate everybody hey where
are you where are you where are you
where are you where are you can't go
that way am i doing what am i doing I
can't go that way
Maria where are you oh you are a genius
yeah yeah and Enya and then I stay back
you [ __ ] okay I'm son of us hey Thomas
okay we're good oh okay let's go back we
still got more backtracking to do now I
don't know where to go where do I go for
new job where all these new ICPs that
people have been telling me about okay
which door did I go through before oh
yeah I need to go through a 1 6 8 - s
containment chamber
I'll leave need a new stuff that'll be
where I need to go but first let's take
a meander walk and to
hi hi buddy are you still in there I
thought you broke out a long time ago
carry on nothing happening oh ah you
memory violation right there what the
hell
you have a batch this is this is
stubborn
hello stahma Hazama I got I got I got
whose is it I can't take it anymore
perhaps in 3 2 1 OOP okay
screw it that whole fav game it's just
stupid the whole thing a marker run oh
no market a poner X X X X X 1 cuz no
okay that was not taken okay disable the
interested I regarding no cuz that all
oh is crap does all crap
so everybody remember the name of markup
owner X X X X ax will be famous someday
my amazing youtube name oh come on hurry
up what was going on with that snake but
it was it was [ __ ] with me at every
turn it was like just it was so
unbelievably Toback it was stupid
they stolen fixed a memory access
violation bug good
okay so we're in a brand-new day
brand-new day brand-new game
I got a mess with Nate up - where'd you
go where'd you go where'd you go where'd
you go where'd you go where'd you go
where'd you go where'd you go where'd
you go where are you huh you were just
here gotta get the gas masks
barely did I get it I don't know yet I
can't look away don't get it
I got it okay okay are you oh there you
are see a head space bar mother hit the
space bar I thought I could jump huh Wow
I did did - dad I need the gas mask you
stupid son of a [ __ ] is that a man what
I'm crouching what why was i crouching
the shorts way out
this is free
all right all right all right oh yeah oh
yeah give me my stuff I'll be on my way
oh you're obviously not down here ah
give me my gun man didn't get it I
didn't get it where is it where is it
where is it where is it back did I get
it oh hi hi hi hi hi hi batteries
batteries
everybody needs batteries right hmm you
know get out of his stupid douche get
out of here okay now now we can carry
forward forward forward always fall up
are you down here too good cuz I was
about to unleash my super powers how
many people know that I have super
powers I do don't question me I do okay
what is this this seems new oh yeah this
is the new layout for the thing I hear
water okay okay let's not go that way
that don't look too promising
oh it's just a containment cell I don't
need you on there okay the only
alright save link open well I know
you're in there I'm just looking cuz I
know you're a dick security card in here
too so I go to hell okay yeah freak out
why don't you what is this oh there's
another thing oh that's a water I swore
I heard like a voice okay let's check
the boat for the doors first um that
leads to a dead end so no need to go
down there wait does it look double
check exactly what we're dealing with
here okay it's a completely blank no
possible help and closed um cake okay
I'm right only way to go is follow I
don't think my card will get me in here
please
no need higher security clearance to get
through the door
alright find another one of these things
eh well you're certainly giving me
plenty of choices
see that's was that a sheet of music a
sheet of music
why is sheet of music so hazardous I
need higher clearance let me check the
other one first you were you go you seem
to go nowhere but maybe somewhere let me
go this way first though cuz this seems
new ish I've never seen this sheet of
music before I kind of want to go to
there what is this
what is this what is this this is
nothing what is this I want to go
through here I want to go to there I'll
pass nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope not doping that with a 10-foot Pole
ha I'm out of time
god damn it okay alright so we're in a
new save we're in a new area a new place
of mystical adventures where we can have
happy fun times all day long so thank
you all so much for watching
hahaha ow [ __ ] yo I didn't close the
door behind me did I oh I did
I didn't I didn't close doors by amnok
us to have stars what's wrong with me
what's wrong with me because you must
never mind so thank you all so much for
watching click the information for
produce it I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
haha
ah
knock on door
buzz
Oh